I usually talk about obsessions on my
show I hear you have one with murder
mysteries since I've been like 12 years
old I've been fascinated with why people
do what they do and don't do what they
don't do mmm isn't that interesting yeah
I mean if you really can figure out why
people do the things they do and don't
do the things they don't do you got a
real leg up on the world yeah you can
figure out a fix that crazy think you've
devoted a whole podcast to these
mysteries yeah what does that say about
you that you like murder
a whole podcast you better hope that's
not true you know how to get away with
it you know you figure out why people do
this then you can figure out ways to
keep him from doing it right you can
figure out how to stop this from
happening kind of spot on before they do
it yeah and because you deal with things
like what I'm doing now is about Chris
Watts the family Annihilator he just
killed his pregnant wife and his two
little girls and he didn't give any
reason well he's given him now Wow okay
that would be interesting to hear yeah
exactly and they you know your story
goes a whole lot better when you're the
only one telling it and as soon as
people started asking questions he
folded up like a puppet a puppet in a
windstorm he just bang he just gave it
up and now he's in you'll be in jail for
the rest of his life he's destroyed all
of these lives for absolutely no reason
yes I'm saying but you're gonna find the
reason right that's the whole point I
love I love that's so scary but
interesting yeah I don't know that kind
of stuff really trips me I can't watch
Dateline I can't watch any of that stuff
yeah well you don't want to listen this
podcast maybe I won't maybe you come
with like a fun one like a fun podcast
like one where people live I'd love to
go deeper would you be willing to let me
analyze you a bit more oh listen if
you're willing to go in here I'm ready
listen
[Applause]
okay you are obviously on the couch I
mean your legs are gonna be really high
imma see it's a very high seat now they
are in the yeah but fall asleep in
therapy if this is what it looked like
actually maybe like open up and I'd be
like you sure this is a trip you want to
take yes yes let's do it
okay so when was the last time you
really cried I'm crying inside right now
oh so you're uncomfortable around people
okay okay okay
what's the one thing in life you're
still trying to find my hair
[Laughter]
I swear you can borrow mine I went to
bed when I woke up the next morning I
was 12
that's alright it's tough I like it you
know a long time that 78% of men would
amputate a body part rather than be bald
I know when they wouldn't to be it's
useful um what is the one thing you tell
16 year old phil gonna tell 16 year old
phil what you are going to love your
life that you'd like to change one trade
of mine I'd like to change I talk so
damn slow wait you know what I feel like
when I'm on the voice of Blake Shelton
and he doesn't from higher-up so it
takes longer to hit your ears how men
talk faster but then there are times
when I get going and you know people
think it twelve to fourteen hundred
words a minute and talk at 125 words a
minute and Robyn well sometime guests up
to 160 but I'm talking about I talking
about 80 or hundred so I think we
average out between the two of us she's
Robin's like me what's this secret
actually what's the secret to being
married for 43 years
well there's a couple actually okay
I learned that whenever she says what it
isn't that she didn't hear me she's
giving me a chance to change what I said
you need to recognize those
opportunities I married her for her
looks but not the ones I get sometimes
in the kitchen I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this